face masks they've played a key role in
slowing the spread of kova 19 but now
nearly two years in experts are
questioning the kind of mask we're
wearing and if it's time to upgrade we
break down what the recommendations are
and stop in at the las vegas medical
store to find out what's available right
now
since kofi began business has been
hectic
at las vegas medical store off sahara
marion contressa works in customer
service she says for the past month
people have been buying in bulk doubling
up on masks it's mostly people that
travel out of town that are looking for
those k 95s but they still purchase the
regular mass surgical masks ii cover
so they wear too
when they travel what is the best mask
to wear right now as new variants
continue emerging many experts are
advocating for the widespread use of n95
masks because the common cloth face mask
they say are not as effective against
the new variant n95s with the proper fit
can filter up to 95 percent of particles
in the air and make a large difference
in protection from infection the next
best mask after that surgical masks
followed by double or triple layered
cotton masks so what's the difference
between n95 and kn 95 mass while they
both are rated with 95 percent
filtration efficiency but the main
difference boils down to what countries
certified the standard of quality of the
mask and 95 are niosh certified that
means they're approved by the national
institute of occupational safety and
health
kn95 masks are manufactured in china and
meet standards specific to china this is
the k-95
and it's 19.99 how many are in here 10
of them marion says right now they only
have kn 95 masks in and have rush
ordered their n95s we're actually
waiting on the n95s
which
it usually takes right now about a month
to two months to get anything
you can find n95 mass online with major
retailers like amazon home depot and cvs
when shopping for an n95 mass the most
important thing to look for make sure
it's tested and certified by the
national institute for occupational
safety and health